okay let's cut to the chase rayleigh
is a goddamn legendary character that is
oozing charisma
authority and mystery like treble the
snort
a character that is respected by all and
has been the main reason that luffy is
now able to challenge
actual yonko and is back on track to
becoming pirate king
after the most traumatic moment in his
life
and so even though we actually don't
know all too much about his past
i want to use this chance to not only
discuss rayleigh's character and his
role in the story
but also delve a bit deeper into the
classic trope of the mentor
and how if used correctly it can enhance
the fabric of a story
significantly oh yeah and why the hell
is he called the dark king
this is the story of the dark king
silver's
rayleigh
[Music]
first of all can we all acknowledge just
how fantastic rayleigh's introduction
was in the story
out of all the great ones we've gotten
i'm thinking kaido
katakuri or emu this might have actually
been my
favorite one and by that i mean the
entire sequence
it's simply done fantastically
especially in the anime
there is no music just the slave
auctioneer
suddenly collapsing then we just see
this giant sitting there and
holy damn this huge ass guy must have
done something right
but he turns around calls out the old
man sitting next to him for
using something called haki and then
this
this is just the right way to reveal an
epic character like this
that right there has a real shock effect
and the way that rayleigh then enters
the hall later
takes a look at the scene deduces what
happens before
knocking out all the guards how could
you not be intrigued by this mysterious
old man that we now know was the right
hand of the pirate king himself
now rayleigh's name has actually two
sources of inspiration
one is so walter rayleigh an english
16th century explorer and privateer
and the other is a phenomenon known as
rayleigh scattering rayleigh scattering
refers to the scattering of light off of
the molecules in the air
thus changing its wavelength for example
it's light hitting the molecules in our
atmosphere that give us
a blue sky so rayleigh literally
scattering kizoru's light attacks
seems to be a science pun by oda i guess
now the silver in his name of course is
a running theme within the roger pirates
with gold roger
silva's rayleigh and skopper gibany
kevin
personality wise as most of the former
roger pirates we've met so far
roger shanks odin and with the obvious
exception of buggy
rayleigh is an extremely eccentric
charismatic
and joyful person that seems to be
enjoying life to its fullest
and since the roger pirates in many ways
seem to have been quite similar to the
straw hats in terms of their crew
dynamics
it comes as no big surprise that
rayleigh gets along with all of them
quite perfectly and even more so is
immediately likable for us readers as
well
after all this guy has the exact same
values and approach to life
as our heroes but more powerful
mature and confident
[Music]
and the detail that i personally found
really interesting in this context is
that rayleigh as a character
shares a lot of characteristics with
both zorro
and sanji now hear me out just like
zorro
rayleigh is the first mate of the roger
pirates the
right hand of the pirate king and the
first person recruited
both are powerful swordsmen that are
only second to the captain
in terms of strength and just like zorro
rayleigh also has a scar above his eye
has a bit of an alcohol problem and just
as zorro manages to get
lost a lot rayleigh seems to have a
tendency to get shipwrecked as
happens on his way to amazon lilly and
after roger's death where he is saved by
hachi
and of course both of them seem to enjoy
a good battle
[Music]
now on the other hand just like sanji
the first thing rayleigh says
is how much he loves women before
showing us his swordman skills he
actually stops kizuru with
a quite sanji-esque kick also as we see
in the auction house he shares sanji's
cunningness and tendency to go on small
infiltration missions
in fact he actually lets himself get
captured on purpose to steal money from
the slave auction that he had lost
while gambling sanji and zorro
no wonder you can't help but find this
man absolutely awesome now in terms of
his role in the story
rayleigh in many ways fits the
archetypical trope of the mentor
pretty much perfectly the mentor
typically is an experienced advisor and
confidant for the protagonist
that passes on his knowledge and wisdom
so that people can live better lives and
society in general can improve
this character not always but very often
comes in the form of the wise old man or
woman
that is better skilled faster and more
experienced than their students and now
pass these traits onto them at this
point in time they might have grown too
old or too fragile for the tasks or
have their own job to do famous examples
of this trope include yoda in star wars
or tony stark in avengers endgame or to
go more into anime
biscuit in hunter hunter or almighty in
boku no hero
their role is to introduce a new skill
and or set of
ideas and values often hoping to pass
the torch
because they know that their role in the
world is slowly coming to an end
and of course most of the time expect
them to have the same elderly but
powerful look
associated with the grandpa gods
i think you will agree that rayleigh
hits this description
pretty perfectly though compared to some
other manta figures he doesn't have to
die to get their disciple on their feet
we're talking gandalf
dumbledore or jiraya here
for luffy this push is replaced by ace's
death
a small twist on the trope here
i got all now what does this mental role
mean for his relationship with luffy
rayleigh is pretty much the closest
thing that luffy could ever get to being
mentored by roger himself
rayleigh is a relic of the pirate king's
era someone who is respected by everyone
even marines like garb or even kizuru
who doesn't seem to have a lot of
respect for anyone else
[Music]
now based on the stories he's heard from
shanks as well as his personal
experience with luffy
he believes him to be the man that roger
has been waiting for
in other words the man he started the
great pirate era for
in the first place
[Music]
luffy wears his former captain's hat has
a similar
quirky crew and most importantly he has
the exact same dream as roger
though we as an audience still don't
know what that dream is
and so i think it's no coincidence that
rayleigh thinks of roger's last words
after luffy leaves
[Music]
luffy has literally inherited raj's will
and
thus roger didn't die now obviously
after the events at zabaodi and
especially marine ford
rayleigh is fully aware that luffy won't
be able to continue his journey into the
new world at the level that he's
currently at
and so i'm not sure if you remember this
it's actually rayleigh that proposes and
sets up the time skip and decides to
teach luffy as much as he can in two
years
so he actually has a chance against the
monsters waiting in the new world
as a result not only does he pass down
his own knowledge and skills onto him
but also is the one to mentally help him
recover from his trauma
and rekindle his belief in himself and
his ability to protect his crew
and yet in the manner of any good mentor
despite being enormously strong and
respected
rayleigh's time is over and the fact
that despite someone as strong as him
being around
the world still being as messed up as it
is also serves to show us just
how powerful this system is and how
difficult it is to actually change the
worlds
okay so that's all nice and well but
let's talk about the elephant in the
room
why is this man called the dark king
there have been a number of speculations
about this but there are two things here
that i want to highlight
one is the actual meaning of the
japanese world
meo if you watch too much anime like
i do you might know the word mao which
means
demon king or the devil mayo on the
other hand
is the literal japanese name for pluto
or
if you prefer greek or latin hades
the king of the underworlds now please
feel free to theorize as to what this
might mean in the comments
i'd love to hear your ideas as for me
the quite obvious meaning here is that
rayleigh
especially as a user of congress hockey
was
pretty much a king himself one of the
strongest people in the world
the fact that this is obviously not an
epithet he picked for himself
suggests to me that he was seen as the
king in roger's shadow
almost as powerful almost as dangerous
but since raja was the one who shown the
brightest
rayleigh was the dark king
now i'm just gonna assume you haven't
seen all of my analysis videos
yet so please click here to check out my
playlist
also i wanted to use this moment to say
thank you to all my patrons and channel
members
you guys really make this all possible
if you want to become part of the
channel get
early access to all my videos and other
perks all while supporting my work here
i invite you to become a channel member
or check out my patreon page
thanks for